les conditions de travail des québécois
s'apprête à subir d'importantes
transformations un document obtenu par
radio canada révèle l'ampleur des
changements que le gouvernement
couillard aimerait apporter à la loi sur
les normes du travail
l'objectif est clair donner du temps aux
travailleurs mais la ministre se garde
bien de commenter vous aurez l'ensemble
de l'oeuvre au moment opportun en temps
quand on sera prêt pour déposer le
projet de loi actuellement un salarié a
droit à trois semaines de vacances après
50 services québec voudrait offrir cette
troisième semaine après 3 en service
autre changement
en plus des dix congé sans solde pour
obligation familiale
les travailleurs obtiendrait deux congés
payés de congé qui pourrait aussi être
utilisée en cas de maladie ou de
violence conjugale à l'assemblée
nationale le pq et la caq montre de
l'ouverture nous mêmes on est en
préparation de propositions qui vont
aller dans ce sens là ça fait partie
d'un des objectifs importants de la caq
de mieux aider les familles seul québec
solidaire fustige les propositions du
gouvernement
ce qu'on a besoin c'est un remède de
cheval puisqu'on entend sma pincée de
l'homéopathie le milieu des affaires est
également sceptique
on ne sait pas combien coûteront ces
mesures et on craint des impacts
négatifs pour les petites entreprises
s'est pas tu donnes une semaine de congé
de plus que le problème c'est qu'il faut
remplacer la personne pendant ce temps
rien coup double à l'opposé des
militants pour les droits des
travailleurs crois qu'il faudrait offrir
beaucoup plus de congés payés en donnant
deux jours de congé il admet qu'il y
certainement qu'il lacunes dans ce
dossier là mais on pense qu'il y aurait
pu faire davantage mais le gouvernement
à d'autres propositions pour les
travailleurs par exemple leur offrir
deux congés payés plutôt qu'un seul pour
assister aux funérailles d'un proche
les prochains dans pourrait aussi rester
plus longtemps à la maison pour
s'occuper d'un malade
les intentions du gouvernement ne sont
pas définitives car le dépôt de son
projet de loi est attendu d'ici le
printemps
ici alexandre duval radio canada québec